[Music]
here's some nothing getting in the way
of our adventure Emily I can't go to
South America wait what my band is
really blowing up right now and where
I'm going there's gonna be like a ton of
illustration inspiration I keep talking
over you but it's sounding like you're
saying [ __ ] yes I heard that time you
poor thing you look awful thank you okay
Jesus it's a long hug all right okay mom
look how fun you were hacked your bags
we're going to South America absolutely
not everybody knows you need two years
to plan a vacation you don't do anything
fun anymore
that's not true I'll be taking sculpting
glasses at the Y Dada I told you I would
not acknowledge that that's frightening
and you made that okay
Oh mom checking for Middleton what's
this well darling oh well what welcome
Oh welcome they're not servicing that
I've got it why are you dressed like a
beekeeper son is dangerous you would get
so much on you put so much on we're
going out thing I'm definitely not
you're gonna miss this whole trip
everything shouldn't be so scary hi I'm
James
thank you
that was not what it looks like it
looked like you were washing it with
your honor in the sink but I need is an
amazing adventure where the hell are we
the scenic route we did you come to
South America I never wanted to cover
the cultural experience I don't speak
any Spanish I don't what they called me
at the restaurant
buthow which having princess is prettier
no it means [ __ ] that checks out I'm
gonna get us out of this
I know a man he can take care of you
that's how sex slavery starts okay mom
most people want young beautiful females
you are both safe it would be so lucky
to [ __ ] us kid
oh no I will be very unlucky you're like
melted candles fat saying where did it
all go how did we end up like this
[Music]
there's a lot of seats you know in this
train
[Music]